Es el factor de riesgo mundial número uno de muerte prematura y morbilidad.
La mitad de adultos estadounidense tiene hipertensión.
Y solo la mitad la tiene bien controlada.
En general ocurre porque hay dos o tres clases de medicación diferente.
Es difícil adecuarse a la medicación de la presión sanguínea.
Cada día hay 500 muertes por hipertensión descontrolada eludibles en EE. UU.
Pero estamos en la era de esfigmomanómetros conectados.
La FDA ha aprobado un esfigmomanómetro que puede llevarse en el reloj.
Ya hay dispositivos de presión sanguínea sin brazalete basado en un radar
que transmite de forma continua la presión sanguínea.
Así se puede revisar la presión sanguínea sir ir a la clínica.
Mi médico podrá ver mis datos y mi evolución en tiempo real
y modificarlas si es necesario.
Con algoritmos para dosificar la presión o utilizando el Internet de las cosas,
la tecnología puede hacer mucho más.
Mi reloj inteligente ya tiene un EKG incorporado
y se puede leer mediante inteligencia artificial.
Ahora mismo llevo un pequeño parche
que retransmite mis signos vitales en directo.
Vamos a echar un vistazo. De hecho, ahora mismo son un poco preocupantes.
(Risas)
Bueno.
No es solo que podamos ver mis signos vitales en tiempo real.
Podría ser información retroactiva para modificar la dosis y la medicación.
Incluso mi peso puede supercuantificarse.
Mi peso, mi forma, cuánta masa corporal, grasa y masa muscular debería tener.
Y utilizarlo para mejorar mi prevención o mi tratamiento.
Y ya no solo por ser experto en tecnología,
los ingenieros del MIT han configurado el wifi
para que podamos recopilar nuestros signos vitales constantemente.
Con nuestros anillos y colchones inteligentes
podemos compartir este escape de datos, nuestros digitome.
Incluso hacer una colaboración, compartiendo nuestra información médica.
Igual que con Google Maps, pero no con la conducción, con la medicina global.
Y eso es genial.
Ahora podemos recopilar esta información.
¿Qué pasaría si los laboratorios pudiesen ir desde la central a sus casas y móviles?
¿E incluso a sus cuerpos para medir los niveles de medicación y demás?
Es la era de la genómica. Ahora, secuenciarse cuesta menos de mil euros.
Y empiezo a entender mi farmacogenómica.
Cómo afectan mis genes; si necesito subir, bajar la dosis o una medicación diferente.
Imaginemos que nuestro médico tuviese esta información integrada en su trabajo.
Aumentado con inteligencia artificial, IA, o como lo llamo yo, aumento inteligente,
y utilizar esa información para saber, de los 18 mil medicamentos aceptados,
cuál podría ser la dosis y combinación correctas para ti.
Puede que ahora podamos mejorar la medicación y la dosis.
El problema es que usamos esta tecnología para mantener el ritmo de medicación.
Y, por supuesto, estas tecnologías evolucionan.
Hay dispensadores electrónicos, aplicaciones con avisos.
Tapones inteligentes que envían mensajes si no te has tomado tu medicación.
Amazon acaba de adquirir la compañía PillPack.
Muy pronto tendremos envíos inmediatos de medicamentos mediante drones.
Ahora todo esto es posible.
Pero seguimos tomando varias pastillas. ¿Qué pasaría si lo simplificáramos?
Una solución sería utilizar mejor el policomprimido.
Un policomprimido es la incorporación de varios medicamentos en uno solo.
Tenemos remedios comunes sin receta contra los resfriados y las gripes.
Hay estudios de sus obstáculos, mezcla de estatinas, presión, aspirinas,
los cuales han mostrado que reducen el riesgo comparado con el placebo.
Pero estos no estaban personalizados, no estaban configurados para el individuo.
¿Qué pasaría si mejoramos el policomprimido personalizado?
Para así poder crearse, basarse y adaptarse a uno, incluso cada día.
Estamos en la era de la impresión 3D, uno puede hacer sus propios brazaletes.
Sus audífonos, aparatos ortopédicos...
Incluso escanearse y tener sus vaqueros hechos a medida.
Así que esto me hace pensar.
¿Qué pasaría si pudiésemos imprimir los policomprimidos personalizados en 3D?
Así, en lugar de tomar seis medicamentos, por ejemplo, podría integrarlo en uno.
Sería más fácil, mejoraría el compromiso e incluso se podrían integrar suplementos.
Como la vitamina D o la CoQ10.
Con la ayuda de estos "InteliMeds" y mi equipo de ingenieros especializados
hemos creado el primer prototipo de impresora de Medicina Inteligente.
Funciona así: en lugar de comprimidos enteros hay micromedicamentos.
Con 1 o 2 mg de cada, elegido con la dosis y combinación ideal para cada individuo.
Y por supuesto, serían dosis y combinaciones que se tomarían juntas,
medicamentos aprobados por la FDA.
Podríamos cambiar la farmacocinética
mediante la estratificación de elementos en los micromedicamentos individuales.
Y cuando presionemos imprimir,
se imprimiría la mezcla de medicamentos necesaria para nosotros en un día.
Empezaríamos por medicamentos genéricos para los problemas más comunes.
Un 90 % de los medicamentos recetados hoy en día son genéricos de bajo coste.
Y una vez la pastilla está impresa, podríamos añadirle algo de parafernalia.
Podríamos imprimir el nombre del paciente, fecha, día de la semana, código QR.
Podríamos imprimir medicamentos distintos para reducir los esteroides a un paciente.
O reducir los medicamentos para el dolor.
Esto es una muestra de nuestro prototipo de impresora de medicina inteligente.
Descubrámoslo.
Tiene aproximadamente 16 silos diferentes
y cada uno contiene micromedicamentos individuales.
Y puedo configurar el software de dosis individuales.
El brazo robótico ajustará la altura y los micromedicamentos se liberarán.
Ahora puedo...
Automatizado, gira y circula para asegurar que los micromedicamentos se han cargado.
Y al presionar imprimir...
Caería por el aparato y ya podría sacar el policomprimido personalizado impreso
con la dosis y la medicación perfecta para mí.
Y si volvemos a las diapositivas, verán todo el proceso.
Cómo los silos seleccionan los medicamentos
y bajan a los diferentes silos, acumulándose en un comprimido.
Bien, esto es genial.
Puedo imprimir mis medicinas a medida, en lugar de tomar seis pastillas.
Puedo ver mi dosis individual.
Mi reloj vigila mi presión sanguínea, necesitaba un ajuste en su medicación.
Mi nivel de warfarina, si mi sangre es poco espesa,
pues bajo la dosis de warfarina del micro medicamento, un anticoagulante.
Mi médico o cardiólogo podría adaptarlo de forma inteligente al día a día.
Estas impresoras podrían estar en la farmacia de la esquina,
en la oficina de su médico, en una clínica rural.
Al final se podrían reducir para tenerlas en casa.
Con cartuchos integrados como este, distribuidos mediante drones.
Imprimir su policomprimido personalizado en la cocina o en el botiquín cada mañana.
Esto podría evolucionar y mejorar el nivel de compromiso por todo el mundo.
Espero podamos reimaginar el futuro de la medicina de formas innovadoras.
Avanzar de polifarmacia, dosis única, bajo compromiso y complicaciones,
a una era de medicamentos personalizados, precisos y disponibles por encargo
que pueda llevarnos y personalizar nuestra propia salud.
Y la salud y la medicina alrededor del planeta.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Presentadora: Daniel, esto es impresionante.
De verdad.
¡Pregunta para ti!
¿Cuándo será capaz, el paciente del asilo que has mencionado,
de imprimir sus pastillas en casa?
Daniel Kraft: Bueno, esto solo es un prototipo.
Creemos que la regulación será de forma automática.
Concretamente en los asilos, la gente toma varios medicamentos
que a veces se confunden.
Sería un lugar idóneo para empezar con estas tecnologías.
Esto no va a evolucionar y empezar con impresoras en el botiquín.
Necesitamos ser inteligentes e ingeniosos sobre cómo lo damos a conocer
siendo conscientes de los muchos retos en cuanto a dosis, compromiso y precisión.
Y hoy en día, con toda esta tecnología
que puede integrarse y obtener ventajas
necesitamos acercamientos como este para tener un futuro en salud y medicina
Presentadora: Genial, gracias. DK: Gracias.
(Aplausos)